THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE'LL CHECK BACK IN SOON.
JOHN.
>> John: LET'S BRING IN DAVE
RUBIN, HOST OF RUBIN REPORT ON
YOUTUBE.
THE IDEA THE MIGRANTS ARE BEING
MISLED WHERE THEY ARE GOING,
ONLY THING I SAW WAS THE
MIGRANTS DROPPED OFF AT THE
NAVAL OBSERVATORY THOUGHT THEY
WERE GOING TO UNION STATION,
MIGHT HAVE BEEN TURNED.
YOU KNOW, THIS IDEA THAT THIS IS
BECOMING INCREASINGLY POLITICAL,
THAT GREG ABBOTT IS BUSSING THEM
TO THE GATES OF THE NAVAL
OBSERVATORY, DeSANTIS TO
MARTHA'S VINEYARD, LORI
LIGHTFOOT IS BUSSING ILLEGAL
MIGRANTS FROM DOWNTOWN TO A
REPUBLICAN SUBURB, AND EL PASO
IS BUSSING THEM TO NEW YORK
CITY, NOBODY IS COMPLAINING
ABOUT THAT.
BUT THE FACT MORE THAN 2 MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE CROSSED THE BORDER
AND SOMETHING HAS TO GIVE HERE.
>> RIGHT.
LET'S DEAL WITH THAT PART FIRST.
2 MILLION PEOPLE CROSSING THE
BORDER, THAT IS THE JOB OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO JUST LOOKING WHERE DO YOU LAY
BLAME FIRST, WHETHER PEOPLE
SHOULD GO TO SANCTUARY CITIES OR
NOT OR OK TO BUS PEOPLE OR PUT
THEM ON PLANES.
NUMBER ONE, EVERYONE HAS TO
UNDERSTAND.
LOOKING FOR WHO STARTED THIS
PROBLEM, IT IS 100% THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION NO MATTER WHAT
JEAN KARINE PIERRE SAYS, IT'S
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
PROTECT THE BORDERS.
AND NOW, BOUNCING ACROSS STATE
LINES AND DIFFERENT CITIES, I
THINK THIS IS QUITE GOOD BECAUSE
IT IS BURSTING FORTH THE
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
DEMOCRAT POLICIES AND REPUBLICAN
POLICIES.
I'M A VERY PROUD NEW FLORIDAAND
DeSANTIS WARNED THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WHAT HE WAS GOING
TO DO.
HE SAID IF THEY COME HERE,
SENDING THEM TO D.C. OR MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
AND I SUSPECT HE'LL SEND THEM TO
D.C., TOO.
TEXAS IS DOING THE SAME THING.
SEEING STATES SAY OK IF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL NOT DO
THEIR JOB, ONE OF THE FEW THINGS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
SUPPOSED TO DO, PROTECT OUR
BORDERS THEN HEY, GO AHEAD AND
GO TO THE SANCTUARY CITIES.
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE FREAKING
OUT NOW THAT, AND THE MEDIA IS
FREAKING OUT THAT THEY ARE
SHOWING UP IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD
AND CHICAGO AND OTHER
DEMOCRAT-RUN CITIES, DON'T YOU
CARE ABOUT IMMIGRANTS?
I THOUGHT EVERYBODY IS WELCOME,
NOBODY IS ILLEGAL, ETC., ETC.,
ALTHOUGH NOW D.C., THEIR
HOMELESS SHELTERS ARE OVERRUN SO
THEY ARE STRUGGLING, TOO.
IT'S EXPOSING THE NONSENSE OF
THE POLICIES, I THINK THAT'S
GOOD.
>> John: THEY CALL THEMSELVES
SANCTUARY CITIES AND YET WHEN
THE PEOPLE SEEKING SANCTUARY
COME THERE, THEY ARE NOT
PARTICULARLY HAPPY ABOUT IT.
ABBOTT SENT THE BUS TO THE NAVAL
OBSERVATORY AFTER KAMALA HARRIS
SAID THIS OVER THE WEEKEND.
>> THE BORDER IS SECURE BUT ALSO
HAVE A BROKEN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM, IN PARTICULAR OVER THE
LAST FOUR YEARS BEFORE WE CAME
IN AND IT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
>> 2 MILLION PEOPLE CROSS THE
BORDER FOR THE FIRST TIME EVER.
YOU ARE CONFIDENT THE BORDER IS
SECURE?
>> WE HAVE A SECURE BORDER AND
THAT IS A PRIORITY FOR ANY
NATION.
>> John: SHE INSISTS ON MULTIPLE
OCCASION THE BORDER IS SECURE,
BUT LISTEN TO WHAT ONE TOLD
GRIFF JENKINS.
>> VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS SAID
THE BORDER IS CLOSED.
IS THE BORDER CLOSED, DO YOU
BELIEVE THE BORDER IS CLOSED OR
IS IT OPEN?
>> IT'S OPEN, NOT CLOSED.
BORDER IS OPEN.
>> THE BORDER IS OPEN.
DO YOU BELIEVE ALL THE MIGRANTS
BELIEVE THE BORDER IS OPEN?
>> EVERYBODY BELIEVES THE BORDER
IS OPEN.
IT'S OPEN BECAUSE WE ENTER, WE
COME IN, FREE.
NO PROBLEM.
>> HOW DID YOU LEARN THAT THE
BORDER WAS OPEN TO COME
ILLEGALLY, HOW DID YOU LEARN TO
COME?
>> BECAUSE SEE IT ON THE NEWS
EVERYBODY COME IN ILLEGALLY.
SO WE DO THE SAME, YOU KNOW.
>> John: SO WHAT THAT MIGRANT
SAID TO GRIFF JENKINS WOULD SEEM
TO STAND IN SHARP CONTRADICTION
TO WHAT THE VICE PRESIDENT
CLAIMED.
>> YEAH, LOOK, I'M SYMPATHETIC
TO THAT GUY'S PLIGHT AND THE
NEWS, WHATEVER COUNTRY HE IS
COMING FROM IS SAYING THE BORDER
IS OPEN AND HE GETS HERE AND THE
BORDER IS OPEN, THUS HE IS IN
AMERICAN TERRITORY, WHO IS
TELLING THE TRUTH?
HIM OR KAMALA HARRIS?
SHE HAS ONE JOB, SHE REFUSES TO
VISIT THE BORDER AND A NATION IS
ONLY A NATION.
SHE BLAMED TRUMP, SAID THE
PREVIOUS FOUR YEARS.
DONALD TRUMP WANTED TO BUILD A
WALL AND REMEMBER WHAT EVERYBODY
SAID, YOU KNOW, PUT UP ELECTRIC
FENCES AND MONITORING, EVERYONE
SAID HE WAS RACIST.
SO IS IT NOW THE POLICIES OF THE
DEMOCRATS WHO APPARENTLY ARE
VERY PRO BORDER, ARE THEY RACIST
NOW, OF COURSE NOT.
SO AGAIN, WE ARE EXPOSING A LOT
OF HYPOCRISY IN THE POLICIES AND
I THINK THIS SHOULD JUST
CONTINUE.
LET'S, YOU KNOW, I THIN
THINK MARTHA'S VINEYARD, JUST
PUT OUT A WARNING, THAT'S JUST
50 PEOPLE WHO SHOWED UP.
WHAT DO YOU THINK HAS BEEN GOING
DOWN AT THE TEXAS BORDER TOWNS
FOR YEARS AND YEARS?
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF